this is me Tekken 8 get ready for the
next battle oh hold on Hollywood rules
$2 you said I pay $85 for Pat Riley
basetball
with the
closeups God salute yeah state of the
art technology state of the art baby so
yeah we here man Tekken 8 it is released
finally out there in stores lambco
currently sitting about a 90 Metacritic
yep still 90 Metacritic right now
reviewing very well
super impressive I just going to give my
overall thoughts obviously you know I've
been you know playing this series for
over 30 years that's crazy that's insane
when you reminded me of that 30 years of
Tekken and I've been there you know for
for the since the very beginning and um
you know it kind of started off as like
a a a knockoff Virtual Fighter clone
that wasn't really as good as virtual
Fighters but I like the limb system you
know each Button had a limb and all that
and then I would say Peak Tekken was
probably three is when they surpass
viral I think three is the yeah the
Pinnacle of Tekken three was Pinnacle
now four was kind of eh five got them
back to go some people feel five is the
Pinnacle I just got to be real like I
know it early I I I've done this story
mode I've done a campaign I've played a
bit and there's still a lot of things I
got to do but the way this is projecting
mhm we could be talking about the
greatest teken of all time it's that
good like like first of all Unreal
Engine
five har to good Lord I don't know what
sorcery y'all doing you know when it's
crazy s we are at the point in Tekken 8
where the
ingame graphics look better than the
pre-run it yeah and I'm just like this
this is this is different like the the
facial animation it is just the effects
the backgrounds I mean the characters
are so distinct they ooze the person now
then I think on series X and you know
it's like 60 with you know 4K 60 but I'm
probably moving down like to 1440 main
consistent shout out to digital founder
they did the break they said the The
Edge did have the series X on on the
graph that a slight Edge there um
doesn't drop no lower than 1440p
consistent frame rate is sick um look
you know the music god tier music I'm
talking about usually every Tech has
about two tracks that are like super
standout this got about like nine you
know what I'm saying and then like as
you go through the story it is just
continually better and better you know
and they did it with the story mod I got
I got to give it up in the sense that
look Tekken evolved the formula as far I
mean Tekken kind of set the trend where
when you come out with a fighting game
you got to have extras they pioneered
that they pioneered having endings in
the game different modes in the game
Tekken ball all this stuff right but
when it came and then each character had
an ending including the sub balls but
when it came now to we get to like the
Mortal cont combats mhm Mortal Kombat
just takes to the next level all the
characters are involved in the narrative
Tekken finally addressing this issue
which is the biggest elephant in the
room with like seven which it's like the
budget seem to be all with the Akuma
story but it's like no one else and then
what are the other characters doing if
you're not a Mishima you know what I'm
saying and now we have that full
rostered kind of Avengers like story you
know what I'm saying with with cin I'm
not going to spoil it but it's really
good um I will say this though there the
Mortal Kombat gang if y'all wouldn't say
yeah that's cool it still ain't messing
with mk's narrative that's fair as far
as serious realistic tone you know for
the most part what I like that Tech is
doing is they are going super anime and
not taking them themselves overly
serious you know what I'm saying they
have them on but yo this this it's
something multiple endings you know Tech
and Force Mode plot twist dope car like
they did that and then the last thing is
you know I mean not the last thing but
um the PVP aspect obviously playing
online now day one was woo little spooky
day one little rough little rough little
rough we we getting we trying to set up
player matches and getting sent the
dashboard and I'm like oh not like this
roll back wasn't rolling back oh was it
was real spooky but the patch
immediately shout out to rod and the
team the next day boom functional
servers things were I I was very
spectator mode for everybody in the so
we could do the rotation you get 8 to 10
you can sh who's private who's not you
know you want other people online to
come in the connection everything
fantastic I've played a lot of ranked
online you know getting my skill in the
net code is strong that was a probably
with Tekken six probably the deet code
is probably not the straight that Tekken
that code has really been bass five to
be honest you know what I'm saying but
nah that's really good now we just got
to see how the balancing works out over
time and the last thing I just say is
the game changers s you going to
appreciate this heat all right heat is a
game changer for the aggressive cuz
remember old teken dudes be turtling
they don't want to fight they want to
back they want a Korean back dash they
want to do all these movement and not
get in and then pick their shots heat
changes to oh you're going to fight cuz
if that heat is on you boss you are
going to get chip damaged away now that
chip damage in fish to the person who's
being super defensive and seeing their
energy go away if they start fighting
back they could regain some lost health
so it's a push pull to get people to get
in the m
you know what I'm saying so you got that
but to me the ultimate Ultimate Game
Changer which is going to take I wish K
was here for
this
yo Tekken ghost
battle that AI is next level this is
where AI is I don't care what nobody
saying super positive for the industry
because let me tell you why the ghost
battles are so dop so let's just say we
all player for the night right me you
Kai The Crew so let's just say Kai or
someone was just really beating you and
trouble you with a specific character
whatever is all your matches you was
just having problems Tekken
automatically saves the replay of every
fight you go to the replay section right
you can do two things first you could
like I'mma download Cognito ghost I
could download his ghost I could how he
fight with his arang I'm I'mma put him
in and I could just mix up with him and
it's AI doing all my Tendencies oh I
like to L Flamingo here I like to start
off the fight here I like to like down
to the science of that is that's me
right so they got the MS down but here's
where it gets Next Level see how if I
was playing head toad Fighters yeah Cog
who whoop me up and down the streets I
play Ai and I beat Cog that's how you
doing it so the thing was next levels
besides the ghost battles that die you
can do this fight against all the people
you've download and you can name them as
a rival you can do all this stuff but
where it's next level is the replay so
now let's just say so me and you were
fighting right we fighting Kai so you
fighting K you're like damn he's giving
me problems with his his gen right or
his devil gy you now go to the match
watch the replay the replay tells you
during the fight that you're watching yo
sa when you he was doing that string all
that was high you could have ducked it
stops it didn't didn't let you enter the
replay let you enter the replay at the
moment they giving you the tips to then
work on it and fight in real time in the
real play yeah I didn't I didn't I
didn't do all of that yet oh my God the
replays is crazy then you could go back
to watch it rewind and fast forward it
then he'll even have things like all
right see you was blocking that you
could have punished him with this here
are some suggested moves so this is all
about getting people better you see what
I'm saying the ghost battle and
the is next level I wish king was here
cuz I was going to talk about Lord I Ain
Lord AI but I was going to talk about
Pro this is where AI could be good for
gaming right this is where a situation
where you like yo fighting games need
this like this is so next level br there
was a dude online that was tearing me up
with Leo I was like yo I can't he's he's
whiffing me he's doing these stances
he's doing all stuff man if I ain't
download that man ghost put it in and I
was just do I was like oh I can stop
this is what I could do to stop it now
this is what he's doing okay and then C
you are familiar you know how it is when
remember when Eddie Gordo first came out
you're like oh good lord but to do
there's characters like that I see so
it's it's such a Next Level Jump For
Fighting bro I'm telling y'all right now
crazy champ is here The champ is here
I'm telling y'all right that teken man
I'm just saying I'm just like yo they
they doing a phenomenal job they really
did it um I know it's early but it could
be the goat it could like it's already
feeling like that and it's it's really
good so highly advise if again oh last
thing if you a dude that don't play
fight game you like nah son I can't do
this this what it is I'm telling you
right right now I forgot about arcade
mode which is you make a literally
Avatar that looks like a little Nintendo
Wii kind of thing you make your man and
the game goes through a story mode of
going from arcade to Arcade and they
have all these characters teach you
little aspects of teken te you how to
get up how to use the new system like
for someone who's completely new you do
that and if you still suck at you still
don't dad mode special Style special to
put the thing on one button and you
could get the combos out listen Tekken
still have
I got it I know it's early but as far as
tekkin go yeah this this definitely feel
like the goat level all those things you
talked about uh at the end at the end
right there I tried in the demo I tried
the little arcade mode going you know
place to place and yes every time you go
to a different place you will get
somebody in the arcade showing you hey
let me show you this aspect of the
fighting of the system let me show you
what heat does let me show you all this
and it's a stepbystep way to get you
ingrained in there so that that to me
from the beginning I was like yes
because I know Street Fighter did it I
was like they need to figure out a way
to on board people in a way because
teken is is complicated game it is it is
simp there's nothing like that in Mortal
Kombat I would actually feel a little
bit more um like I would feel a little
bit more confident on
playing like Tekken or like online
because they have an aspect like that
like Mortal Kombats like yeah you just
got to learn or just don't play don't
play yeah with Tekken um right the core
of it is simple because again you go
back to the whole idea of left punch
Right Punch left kick right kick that is
the basis for it that is it and then you
can combine make combinations of those
to get combos out grabs different things
and a lot of that stuff you can just you
can map to you know triggers and stuff
to make it easier for yourself but the
biggest key to Tekken is always been
understanding
distance understanding the pecking game
with what they call okazi right the
ground game right the ground game the
get up game and understanding that for
every move that somebody does there are
multiple ways to counter it and punish
it and it's a matter of you kind of
learning your own style what you like to
interrupt you not this is where it gets
Next Level you know the traditional Tech
is you go to your character then you go
to your move list in the move list
there's a separate thing not only just
your move set for the character it's
also okay
punishable moves when somebody keeps
blocking you when someone does like they
have scenarios and they have scenario
command list moves to tell you when they
use certain moves this is what it's
effective for that's different for
different scenarios in the fight so now
you like oh yeah I'm struggling against
somebody that blocks all the time here
is low this what you do for pressure
here has a combo it it really is helping
the player but continue yeah no no it to
me that level of depth has always been
impenetrable for a lot of people right
we used to always buy the Prima gu every
time we bought the game you buy the
Prima guide with it with all the move
sets whatever and then we would go into
the dojo and we would just practice
learning the moves first and then after
learning the moves you play against each
other and you fig figure out what works
what works in What scenario and that's
how we learn to play um but again the
game was never really so good at
teaching you it it was good at teaching
you the moves and going in there but
scenarios and sort of teaching you how
to play the game and how to best play
the game it was always us just you know
figuring stuff out on the fly so the
fact that they're realizing hey but for
fighting games to really you know
Elevate the way they were back then and
and we again with with with Street
Fighter 6 and MK1 and now this like
they're back baby they're really really
back game is back man Tekken is is that
highly recommend that's all I got un let
I got any more questions for me on the
game whatever well I just want to give a
little bit of my oh sure I forgot you
picked up I yeah I got it hasn't played
it but um so I downloaded it initially
on the raw cuz I wasn't home to to play
it any so yeah I put it on the Ally um I
saw like John Lan's breakdown for the
steam deck I was like oh so the allly is
going to chew this up like if the steam
deck could get it to 60 the Allies going
to chew it up and yeah um honestly on
default all I did was dro the resolution
down cuz it defaulted to 1080p so I
dropped it to 900 and I got that
60 at medium settings um and you know
the size of the screen means that you
don't have to worry you know about
missing out on detail it looks
absolutely beautiful run smoothly so I
can get my practice
on on the go Dojo on the go it's a
special thing but I went yesterday and I
downloaded it onto the shout out to NZXT
the NZXT player 3 AMD Edition that's
right salute salute let's get let's get
that link in the chat if we can let's go
let's go let's get the n60 up there but
I downloaded it there right and I you
know I just I downloaded it let the game
load up went into the game and I'm like
man it's a little slow like it's a
little slow so I'm like okay I hadn't
looked at what the what it defaulted to
I just was a little slow so I go in and
obviously what it defaults to is it
analyzes your system and says okay you
could your system could do this I go in
if this game did not default to yeah
your system can run this game at damn
near 8K resolution oh yeah
it defaulted to it was almost 8K
resolution and I'm just like what the
hell and and mind you it was just a
little slow I was like it's f it was
still moving it just a little slow was a
little slow I'm like oh okay dude I
dropped it to 4K M everything Ultra oh
oh my God are you applying I need to
test this out or no yes you need yes you
do I need to show you to show my build
mhm mhm yeah oh and speaking of show
your bill we need to see we need to see
that that that Jin statue that your
special edition yeah we got that we got
that
we second a shout out to you know what
I'm saying uh di Dio pad you know what
I'm saying God hooking your boy up let
me see that you see that crispy hold on
let let's let's pin that for a second I
can't there we go pull P that that that
Kazama you know what I'm saying to do
the light up joint collect that's
beautiful man sick bro this joint is
crazy yeah shout out to the snail killer
that was beautiful yeah so I did that I
was like oh my God this so this game
like you know people complain about
unreal that this it you there's hitches
and it's clippy whatever but this they
got this engine singing in this game un
it it is it is a sight to behold on PC
man it really is now I'm playing 4K
Ultra with hdr on he say yeah yeah or it
it is ridiculous and it runs smooth as
butter and like everything you said they
they added everything they needed to it
to be in line with you know MK and to be
in line with Street Fighter in addition
to it just being Tekken and and there's
something very special about Tekken you
know it's it's that 3D space um it's one
thing that I was a little like I have to
I have to get still get used to right
and for me from back in the day it was
like okay there was Virtual Fighter as
the most grounded fighter and it was
Tekken to me where was
like yeah the the moves were grounded
with you know within reason obviously we
were fighting against pandas and you
know whatever but the mov set still felt
relatively grounded in like real martial
arts or whatever right and that hasn't
changed here but like to like you
alluded like the anime of it has
increased exponentially right there's a
lot of explosions devil je devil genes
everybody's on steroids yeah yeah
everybody out everybody every body's
working out everybody beefy so initially
I was like yo it's almost too many
effects while fighting I'm like I I
can't even see the moves that are coming
because there's some kind of sparkling
effect or something like that so I'm
like okay but I asked I asked Kai he
says I can I can adjust that on my end
yes so I don't see all of that and it
looks like a more grounded experience
even though you know it's online it's
playing out as as this crazy you know
bombastic experience because to me that
was the only where it's
like for whatever reason like it it was
just it was a little it threw me off
because I'm like man I'm I I can't see
the move seeing it felt kind of like and
I mind you I felt this way when Street
Fighter started doing it right I was a
street fighter two purist just the super
moves you know Dragon punches and and
and and spinning kick and that's it and
then we started getting supers and I'm
like okay but they're just stronger
versions of their regular mov so okay
that's fine but you know Alpha took it
in another Direction you had like
straight up super moves and now you know
in Street Fighter 6 MK you have literal
like super moves that are full-on like
you know pre-rendered animations or
whatever so um it makes sense that they
would do it in Tekken but it it took a
little bit of getting used to in that
regard but I just love the fact they
don't take themselves too seriously in
the story it's kind of ridiculous and
fun they brought back so Tekken force is
back as well in addition to Tekken it's
technically back but like in a mode I
mean in in the game during the story
there's a part where it kind of comes
back it does it okay okay yeah so I
haven't done the story yet I went in
immediately and just I did King's little
story vignette thing and then I went
right into the dojo to practice so
that's what I've been doing so I need to
get the story mode done this week um but
man uh I I'm just I'm happy I didn't
really jump in on seven like that I was
I got it on Xbox day one I was excited
exed day one and I thought the game was
good I was a little mad that it was 720p
and it was like Blurry and I wasn't
happy with it so I just kind of felt off
but I I you know I need to I need to get
my king back up get back in there I need
to get my Bri Fury back up um Tekken
this back and to your point I it's quite
possible that this is this could be an
all-tim because for me three was
Untouchable three was such three was
such an elevation of that formula um
speaking of games that we made a lot for
we we we all got the import version and
we it was like 90 bucks 100 bucks bro
that game a leave my PlayStation one all
of us all and all of us were playing it
on that not even the modded PlayStation
it was with the with the little eraser
holding the TR over um we did for Tekken
Tekken means a lot to us so no doubt so
it's out there go check it out and um
highly recommend even if you're not in
the fight games but that's all I got
let's add it got anything we going to
move on